the Palestinian flag is painted onto a
houthi helicopter as they film
themselves taking over a cargo ship in
the Red Sea the fighters have increased
attacks on vessels in the Babel MB
Strait since the start of Israel's war
on Gaza and they've become far more
sophisticated in their methods it's
causing a ripple effect in one of the
world's most important shipping routes
it will have an impact an inflation
shock on the global economy if it
increases we already saw uh European gas
prices Jump by 12% UK gas prices jump
and oil uh uh Rose by 4% to around $77 a
barrel from a 5mon low that we saw just
in this last week the US defense
secretary Lloyd Austin is on a regional
tour and has announced the formation of
a multinational task force to patrol
Waters in the region the attacks have
led to several firms suspending
operations in the Red Sea due to the
deteriorating security situation the
British oil and natural gas company BP
is the latest to stop all its
Consignments all these major shipping
companies have already stopped using the
passage with some re-rooting their
vessels around the southern tip of
Africa which can add around 10 days to
the journey the Taiwanese container
shipping line Evergreen is rerouting too
and has said that it will temporarily
refuse to transport Israeli cargo all
this disruption will cause delays to
things like energy supplies grain and
manufactured goods all of which are
transported via the shipping Lane
it comes at a time when the Panama Canal
another major trade route is battling
with a Water Crisis the number of vessel
Crossings have been curtailed due to
Drought induced congestion analysts say
the shipping industry hasn't faced this
kind of pressure in decades the final
list of countries that have joined the
security task force has not yet been
confirmed but notably it excludes
countries bordering the Red Sea and the
Gulf of Aden like Egypt and Saudi Arabia
this is a global issue and for the
houthis it's not just about Gaza
analysts say so there are other ulterior
motives there are political motivations
uh for the for the huis to be continued
doing this it's not just about being in
solidarity with Gaza they they have an
agenda of their own they are linked to
Iran they are aligned with Iran um and
uh want to be governing IR Yemen so the
huis are wielding incredible power right
now over the global economy in in a in a
in a global archery for for World Trade
It highlights how the safety of crossing
a narrow waterway of around just 30 km
wide has far-reaching Global
implications Stephanie Decker Al jaaz